it took ancient explorers thousands of
years to be able to produce detailed
maps of just our continents now every
year we carry on making progress by
leaps and bounds and challenged the
universe by discovering new horizons
5924 spacecraft have been launched from
the earth in the past 60 years many of
them were not to fulfill their missions
and the connection for them was lost
meanwhile others revealed things man
hadn't been able to observe for millions
of years
in 1986 NASA's spacecraft Voyager 2 went
as far as Uranus and today I'm going to
tell you what it managed to observe in
the short time it took to pass one of
the remotest planets in the solar system
Voyager 2 would never have made any of
its discoveries had it not been for
something that happened in the 1960s
that was to revolutionize our today's
perception of celestial bodies in 1964
when Gary flandro then an intern at
NASA's Jet Propulsion Laboratory started
drawing graphs of planets future
positions he soon found that all the
planets beyond the asteroid belt were
going to align in a very narrow sector
of the sky in the late 1970s in our
system this phenomenon occurs once every
175 years and this was a unique
opportunity by performing gravity boost
maneuvers a spacecraft would be able to
whizz from one planet to another thus
exploring them all it would also reduce
the time of the flight which would
greatly boost chances of success however
due to potentially high costs this
ambitious project had to be rejected
that's why NASA came up with something
different in 1977 a cheaper project was
planned namely Mariner Jupiter Saturn 77
even though the two probes were intended
to explore exclusively Jupiter and
Saturn the scientists in charge of their
development designed the probes in a way
for them to be ready for a prolonged
journey the first probes trajectory
allowed it to additionally fast item one
of Saturn's moons with its own
atmosphere as for the second spacecraft
it was able to fly by Uranus and Neptune
half a year before the plant launched it
was decided to change the project's name
thus the voyagers made their appearance
in history of space discoveries
running ahead it should be mentioned
that in their long history the voyagers
have discovered a number of phenomena
whose existence was to be confirmed only
many years later
Jupiter's tumultuous atmosphere
Saturn's changeable rings and Neptune's
dark spot all these discoveries were
made possible thanks to the ambitious
experiment NASA's scientists ventured to
carry out nine years after its launch
Voyager 2 became the only spacecraft to
ever reach Uranus in order to boost up
its connection with the earth as 64
meter DSN antenna and 224 meter antennas
we're raid back on our planet the
spacecraft's cameras were supposed to be
able to beam back several thousand
pictures things we already knew about
Uranus before the voyages approached its
rotation angle nine rings and five of
its satellites the information is
scrupulously gleaned for hundreds of
years by the most prominent minds of our
planet comprised a tiny portion of the
information that has been made available
today thanks to that single Swift flyby
on the 7th of June 1985 the first
navigation pictures of Uranus system
were taken but it was not until November
the 6th that the camera moved on to
taking more detailed images it is quite
extraordinary that the magnetometers
kept silent in November December and
even the first half of January at the
same time the earth radiation meter
quite and down only after the orbit of
Mars while Jupiter's radio emissions
persisted from the very day of the
launch Michael Kaiser from the Goddard
Space Flight Center prophetically
remarked it's either that we've
encountered a planet without a magnetic
field or else it's so bizarre that we
don't know what to look for thanks to
the voyagers investigations it is now
known that Uranus's magnetic field has
some features due to its peculiar
rotation the peculiarity lies in the
fact that the magnetic dipole does not
coincide with the planets rotation axis
it has in fact displaced by 1/3 of its
radius relating to its center
besides the magnetic axis is tilted with
respect to the rotation axis at an angle
of 60 degrees Uranus's magnetosphere
doesn't look like a wide stripe but is
rather lopsided due to the strong tilt
of the rotation axis to the magnetic
axis on the 27th of December 1985
Uranus's latitudinal zones were clearly
visible in the transmitted images
dark-brown in the poles and lie to the
equator on the same day thanks to the
snapshots Steven Sinnott was able to
confirm the discovery of Uranus his
first unknown satellite 1985 u1 it was
traditionally dubbed after a character
from a play by William Shakespeare 15
puck in the following several days
Voyager 2 carried on taking pictures of
the moons among them already known
titania
Oberon Ariel Umbriel and Miranda however
their number grew threefold thanks to
the pictures on the 16th of January 1986
the Voyager 2 project team announced the
discovery of six more moons with the
help of the photos the largest objects
1986 u1 and u2 were discovered in the
photos examined on January the 3rd u3
was discovered on January the 9th and u4
u5 and u6 were registered on the 13th of
January the temporary designations of
Uranus's satellites was substituted by
these up-to-date names twelve Porsche 11
Juliette nine Cressida 13 Rosalind 14
Belinda and ten Desdemona in the images
of January the 20th some details of the
relief on the surface of Oberon titania
and Ariel were distinguishable and two
more satellites were discovered on that
day u7 and u8 6 Cordelia and 7 Ophelia
on January the 22nd Voyager 2 set off in
its first flyby programme v 751
in addition to taking regular snapshots
of the moons it captured the patchwork
of the uranium rings and damn breel in
color in one of the images taken on the
following day Bradford Smith found one
more satellite 1986 u9 it was later
dubbed eight Bianca Miranda or rods
peculiar terrain was a discovery that
amazed NASA's astrophysicists it was
possible to distinguish it thanks to the
voyages pictures the outer layer of
Miranda's crust is covered with
crevasses dales cliffs and ravines which
together form a hybrid of geological
features from different worlds
according to explorers estimates at
least ten types of terrain find
themselves on a celestial body of a
measly 500 kilometers in diameter after
that it was time to discover uranium
rings when Voyager 2 was passing through
the planet's rings plane a great
multitude of dusty particles were
observed 115,000 kilometers away from
the planets core and 60,000 kilometers
away from the outer ring Epsilon it
looked like a diffuse nebula four
thousand kilometers thick thus two new
uranium rings were discovered by Voyager
2 the first string was located between
the Delta and epsilon ones and was given
the temporary designation 1986 u1 are in
direct sunlight it looked very narrow
just about one or two kilometers and
faint and only by using ultraviolet
detectors were astronomers able to
observe it later Uranus his 10th ring
was seen in the images this picture
shows all of them from the bright
epsilon ring to the faint line of the
sixth ring
the existence of the second ring
discovered by Voyager two dubbed 1986
u2r was confirmed only in 2004 it was
located thirty nine thousand five
hundred kilometers away from the planets
core
and within twenty years it had migrated
beyond now finding itself within the
distance of up to forty one thousand
three hundred fifty kilometers away from
the core before bidding farewell to
Uranus and fairing onward towards new
horizons Voyager 2 took its last
snapshot of the planet at the moment
when this picture was taken the probe
was already a million kilometres away
and was making for yet another mystery
of the solar system Neptune
this encounter would herald a major
scientific breakthrough at the same time
billions of kilometers away thousands of
people held their breath in anticipation
of yet another step into the unknown
[Music]
you